[MUSIC]
>> In every industry, there is some
company that really makes a difference.
And in ever one of those companies,
there's a leader who really mattered.
Our vision at the Stanford Executive
Program is to help you become that leader.
[MUSIC]
Our curriculum will bring you to
the cutting edge in the latest
thinking on business excellence,
design thinking, big data.
The latest in financial engineering.
Strategic management.
Methods for innovation.
The faculty at the Stanford Business
School focus on why companies win.
How public policy shapes the success and
failure of economies.
How people and their careers change.
How negotiations, improve or
hurt the chances of a business.
How groups and teams operate
effectively to get the job done.
Helping you to understand what will make
a difference for you as a leader and for
your company as a competitor.
[MUSIC]
Our approach to learning in
the Stanford Executive Program
relies on a great deal of collaboration,
as you,
together with the executives in
the program, share your experiences.
You'll carry with you that network
that you create when you're here.
So that over your career,
your relationships worldwide
in the business community will be enriched
by the six weeks that you had here.
[MUSIC]
You will be changed by
your experience here.
In the short run,
you will have specific plans and
tools that you can execute on Monday
morning when you return to work.
And in the long run, your career and
your business will go onto
a different trajectory because of
the techniques and ideas that you learned.
We're excited about the directions
your career will be taking.
We look forward to seeing
you here at Stanford.
[MUSIC]